situation yeah so obviously i don't know
why you would say that it's not right
for children to be around their father i
can only assume that it's
to their detriment i would only assume
that um i think generally um
yeah like you said children need to need
both parents yes i agree and um when it
comes to like baby father
baby mother um
just just say uh confrontations um when
it comes to children
um 200 children per day
are removed from
their father's life by the court the
family court system okay do you know
what i'm saying and a lot of the time
it's because women have said certain
things about the father
and now whether they're true or not
we don't know but um
i feel like a lot or i see a lot of
women
in these days and times talking about
their baby father and how bad he is
yet and still you kind of chose you kind
of chose that
so i would never speak bad about the
father of my children to my children or
to anyone right where the public or here
um whatever was my decision is between
me and him but like for instance did you
decide to leave
yeah right yeah um but
just because because i think i even have
more respect for him because i have kids
with him just to respect my children i
will never disrespect their dad
so if my children say if i was in an
environment where maybe the father of my
child was not there and my kids kept
asking about their dad i would say
something like he's busy at the moment
but when he's available i will he will
be you know he'll come and see you i'll
never say oh your dad he doesn't have
time for you blah blah i will never do
that because it's not for i'm not doing
all of these things for you i'm doing it
for my kids you know i'm the kind of
woman that i will if he doesn't want to
speak to the kids i would call him to
speak to them because whatever issue
we're going through it's got nothing to
do with them
they didn't come into this world based
on ish problems they came out of
pleasure and love because when you have
sex obviously that's pleasure right so
why would i give them anything but that
i have to give them they have to be in a
pleasurable environment and they have to
feel love
you guys keep talking about you know
choosing the man or you know bad
decisions when you're you know making
children blah blah blah
but you're not acknowledging the fact
that people change as well
the person that you had the baby with at
that time may not be the same person in
two years time so you have to also
acknowledge that as well it's not that
they were a bad person when i chose to
have
this um my baby with them i don't think
i don't think that any of your baby
fathers were bad people yeah so do you
think they were weak that's
did you think they were well i do think
that they were weak why we can't say
from a mentality perspective from a
mentality perspective
it's too there's too much nowadays
around oh god like i can't afford it
like if if i have a kid blah blah blah
whatever there are a lot of women who
step up to the plate
yeah and decide to have a child my mum
being one of them
and
so like my mom being one of them and my
dad literally he had to work stupid
hours he weren't making that much money
he had to make stupid hours to
to like support me and my mom they ended
up splitting up but it wasn't for
financial reasons it was just just
because of
it's just because of things
however now like back in the day if a
guy knew he was having a kid he'd step
up
we've got uber right most of us have
driving license we can do that on the
weekend
plus our full-time job we've got nine
months to prepare for that child
and we got nine months to prepare for
that child now i don't know what
happened in
in any of your relationships but as soon
as i find out that i've made i've made a
girl pregnant or something like that i'm
stepping up yeah it's it's not it's not
even a thing and and that all comes from
a strong mentality
that all comes from a strong mentality
from developing yourself and i know that
i'm quite strong mentally and i think
that people who are quite weak
say nah do you know what like i'm not
like i'm gonna sack this off or don't
even give it a go i mean do you think
when you say people change doesn't that
kind of sound like an excuse no no it's
realistic reality it's not an excuse but
people used to change over your
marriages and you can like like it just
sounds like
the change is not detrimental exactly
it's not it's not
i'm not saying i disagree or agree with
you but if i think about my situation i
feel like one of the biggest problems us
women have is we date potential so you
see a guy you think oh yeah i really
like him
but when i think about the issues in my
marriage the issues i had in my marriage
are also the issues i had in my
relationship they were always there they
just became a lot more heightened when
responsibilities increased so i do think
as a woman i don't feel real i don't
think we realize the power we have on
the path we can have
so i think if we took on that
responsibility i think we will make men
a lot weaker in that element so because
right now it's like men are the prize
men are this men are there but in a way
i feel like they say women are the prize
so don't you think
then no i'm not this i think both
parties are a prize
in in in their own way yeah but i feel
like
men get more praise now and it's well
now or whenever but i think they get
more praise because
it sounds madder because i want to say
we've allowed them
in a sense of
we've given them that power
if we were to use our brains okay
me included what do you mean
so me included right i've given people
i've dated the power to have access to
me even though they may not be good for
me if i took it away you don't have
access to me and i feel like you can be
by yourself
yeah but should i be desperate and be
hurt because i don't want to be by
myself
i think that's very simple
why don't you say on some level you kind
of are what you attract so if you keep
attracting the certain type of guy it
says something
to an extent yes i think i'm saying to
someone today that when i got divorced
the guys i attracted then to the guys i
attract now are very different okay
right so i do think as human beings we
have to take responsibility for maybe
how we carry ourselves how we talk all
those things we do
every little thing i would say as well
and i'm just being realistic here so
when you did get divorced you were a lot
younger right yeah and now you are a bit
older the the amount of so so the pool
of the men that you are going to attract
with two boys
it's going to be a lot less i've never
dated a guy who's got kids i've never
gave the guy who's not wealthy i think
i've even got a better paw now than i
had when i was
younger doesn't count unless you have a
ring like anyone can deal with a rich
guy yeah like i would i would i would
like to i would be dating
i would date you but i would never wire
you
that's your opinion that's fine i'm okay
with that right well but it's like based
on results so like on this show we only
count engagements okay that's and i can
get like a guy gets on a knee and
proposes to you so for for me especially
us being on our port in the comments we
get
i've realized people's opinions don't
matter anymore i think it's what i'm
living that matters so if i say oh i
want to be with a certain type of guy or
i want to do this i want to do that if
i'm not living that i need to sit down
and think about how am i going to
actually get what i want or grace you're
not going to get that because for some
reason it's not working do you get me i
don't really do statistics anymore
because i feel like it's not good for me
so what do you feel like you
feel like statistics don't
matter to you or something it's nice to
hear that's it
so so i'll say okay so statistically
what do you think that i'm a divorced
mother of two
um on the dating market right now in her
what 30s i'm 30 yeah right so what do
you think do you think that there are
guys now out there
who are young suitors with a lot of
money thinking that's exactly what i
want i want a divorce mother of two
mm-hmm
as my babe as as my next wife
would you say that
i'll be in denial if i said yes no i
don't think that's what they're looking
for
however
my
my life doesn't tell me that it seems
like your suitors are quite decent right
so we're talking no kids wealthy